produits et puis à côté de vous clément
lépi dit ce témoin les piliers ce qui
est un poète nouvelliste romancier
après avoir exercé d'ailleurs son métier
et votre cinquième roman paraît aux
éditions du seuil sous le titre la main
rouge et il pourrait porter en sous
titre electre à belleville en 1927
oui bien sûr mai 1927 c'est l'anti 1978
et belleville à cette époque était
croyez moi un sacré quartier
actuellement on est tentant de le
démolir il ne restera plus rien
certainement dans quelques décennies
mais à belleville en 1927
on y chantait on y buvait aussi on y
vivait ferme
on y mange et il y avait des gargotes il
y avait des tavernes
il y avait des petites femmes qui
travaillaient au coin de la rue vincent
il y en avait d'ailleurs qui était assez
particulier puisque on l'appelait la
charentaise lt pinet en chaussons notre
une autre que l'on appelait langue de
velours c'est tout un programme
il y avait trois bals musettes la java
le boléro le ça gaze aussi et nous
avions 15 cinéma de du boulevard de
belleville à l'église à belleville
c'était toute une ville y avait deux
favoris de chaussures il y avait les
artisans arrivent les artisans ce2
grande fabrique de chaussures utilisant
huit mille ouvriers c2 et 400 petits du
fabricant de chaussures c'était de plus
toute une espèce de marmites
bouillonnant de travailleurs de deux
anciens certainement un solide et que
dont vous avez restituer la vie c'est
parce que le personnage principal c'est
peut-être belleville belleville est le
personnage principal
effectivement c'est mon village je
l'aimais
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de le mettre
un peu un premier plan bon mais venons
en aux personnages en ya d'abord la
culbute la culbute c'est une activité
menée de belleville c'est une femme bien
avantageuse te jure je ne traduis
entendu furla pourrait faire une très
belle clytemnestre vous a écouté quand
même on est très drôle la culbute
quand elle trouve son bonheur en
s'accrochant au gigot congelés là dans
l'arrière boutique wii mouche et je m'en
fous du radar et hume
on va écouter sa moelle a du tempérament
si l'udc les aimants mais j'aime
beaucoup j'ai adoré votre façon mais la
culbute
et si la charente pour pension par mois
écrit par 15 degrés dans la chambre
froide qui l'écouté les pommes 1 15
degrés pour et la ccoo croissance et
plus tram leclerc elle le fait pour un
esprit d'ailleurs il ya la légitime car
il suit empoignade entre elles j'aime
bien ça la culbute et quand même elle
est un peu prostituée elle est un peu la
face une femme légère ces salles a du
mal à rester un quart d'heure sans césar
et les bars y est elle est mariée avec
un merveilleux artisans oui un homme
travailleur
ancien brocheurs plus peur d'un show
surnomme qui travaillent dix et quinze
heures par jour qui s'appelle la broche
il s'appelle la wii sont tous des
surnoms oui oui mais vous avez la belge
une autre fois on s'appelait devenu un
ami crohn de cartons et ou parce qu'elle
le peut il salua les copains bec de
cannes pied-de-biche le grand caillou la
rue de romainville oeil en coin alphonse
dit les meules est à cause de sa façon
très personnelle de serre et les femmes
dans ses bras ces dames le manger des
yeux bettina la frileuse amélie la roue
s'est vraiment dit tu mouilles bush
réputé pour ses missions en forme de
poire williams cette fois-ci vous le
savez pourquoi mouche parce qu'il ya une
variété de points qui s'appelle des
mouchoirs
oui alors vont donc elle a un mari alors
travailleurs travailleurs mais bon
artisan qui est fier de son travail
et oui comme tous les cordonniers de
belleville d'ailleurs mais forcément
elle a un amant aussi des matériaux
simples et la pendule alors là c'est le
personnage je crois que c'est peut-être
le personnage que je préfère du livre je
les écris avec beaucoup d'amour et je
laime ce personnage malgré que ce square
peut enfin il a un peu moitié
monte-en-l'air moitié macro enfin vous
voyez vous êtes un petit à petit
gangster m'enfin ils ouvrent les
coffres-forts avec une dextérité à
s'extraire des merveilles au billard
merveille obiwi champion de becker ce
qui se passe et bien et je pense que la
culbute et des deux de son amant trucide
son mari en lui plongeant la tête dans
un seau après lui avoir fait boire un
verre
2-2 de la verte de la version wii d'un
de l'absent de l'absence angoissante on
l'appelait la verte
et effectivement elle pourvoit mulet sur
son lit cage il est en train de gonfler
en train de filer me voir si m
mais il y a deux enfants les entrants
juliette et victor alors juliette trust
avec ça mais enfin dans la même rue
parce qu snare victor on l'envoie la
campagne et puis la culbute les mains
libres pour pouvoir me des grandes
villes victor revient il est même
intervient après avoir déplacé c'est son
oncle et demont et sa soeur lui explique
comment est mort son père parce que
nombreux sont ceux des problèmes était
jeune il dormait il n'a pas vu une app
assister à la au drame et la soeur
sublime
son frère de la mère pour venger le père
nous laisser voilà alors ils vont au
cimetière à pantin est lancée sur le
devant la tombe du père comme lui il
faut tuer vous rangez pas pas venger
papa alors victor dit je ne peux pas je
pourrai pas forcément moi je les fais
son père quand même quand le tuer sa
mère pendant quand même si c'est sacré
boulot mais effectivement il lui il va
le faire
il va défier en un combat singulier la
pendule alors il y aura un combat
singulier qu'on vous dit il va défier la
pendule dans la cour la cour de la grâce
de dieu
après avoir dansé à la java et il va
remonter la rue de belleville en passant
par la rue ramponeau et il va les
chercher sa soeur et tous les deux vont
venir vont aller dans la dans la carte
pour chercher l'outil a tué un marteau
et lui il veut surtout tuer sa mère avec
un emporte-pièce d'heure c'est un an
c'est un engin très coupants avec lequel
on découpe les semelles de cuir mais ne
trouve pas cet engin et il va être
obligé d'aller dans l'ancienne fabrique
de chaussures où travaillait son père au
moment d'ailleurs ou belleville est en
feu non non non il en 1927 belleville a
brûlé enfin une partie de belleville à
brûler ou quel sens prend de la rue des
pyrénées ça a été dans son nid monstres
monstres et je me souviens que les
vitres des maisons avoisinantes manqué
de
de fondre certaines vitres ont fondu et
ça a été fabuleux
je crois que deux pompiers sont morts et
les 20 casernes de paris ont envoyé des
voitures de pompiers est l'apothéose du
roman parce que oui la 110 et puis ces
enfants pictures leur mère y remarque
est pourquoi l incendie parce que le
insolite un peu purificateur envoyé pour
c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi cette
période là je choisis 27 à bon escient
et la lgv a tué sa mère à coups de
l'abordage à coups de marteau ça va être
affreux sa machine créée par tous les
saints les flots vous avez refait
l'histoire d'electre giroflées gilles
d'histoire delek c'est un vieux projet
qui me tenait à coeur depuis longtemps
et electre dans le populo elle est dans
le populo rien de péjoratif il faut oui
dans le peuple
c'est d'ailleurs pas le premier à tenter
la rue c'est un thème éternel lyonnais
dont un thème éternel je crois que
belleville s'accorde très bien
d'ailleurs avec cette histoire qui est
une histoire de famille oui c'est une
histoire de famille electro oui
messieurs à laure belleville c'est tout
à fait le contexte qu'il veut ce qui est
vrai c'est que le sang coule beaucoup
développé la main rouge owen goutte de
sang sur votre ouverture qui tombe parce
que laurence dufour appelé évidemment
que votre livre comment dans une
boucherie vraiment l'amour c'est l'amour
tartare ont pour et puis elle se termine
dans le sang et est dans la cour à la
grâce de dieu il ya cinq cadavres
et si on se bat on se bat aussi rare et
volver mais je veux dire que
primitivement j'avais l'intention de
faire tuer la culbute oparo victor mais
je n'y suis pas parvenu je suis resté
devant ma feuille blanche dans la
machine à écrire pendant à peu près une
dizaine de jours sans pouvoir tuer la
mairie en fait c'était ma propre mère
que je voulais plus et je n'y parvenais
pas alors j'ai effectué la mer par
nation sam était plus facile